Hi, I'm Angela with Life Harmony energies where we bring harmony into your life for improved well-being, health, and happiness.
We recognize that everything in life is energy, and when energies align, there's harmony in our world.
And what better way to keep positive, healthy energies with you at all times than with our beautiful health and harmony jewelry?
The pieces are infused with bio-resonance energy at our European workshop, so they emit special energetic frequencies that come in contact with key meridian points on your body.
I haven't stopped wearing this bracelet since I got it, it's a game changer for me. The energies connect with meridian points in my wrist.
So I benefit from four amazing energies whenever I'm wearing it.
Support for a healthy body and a strong immune system. Anxiety and stress relief and better sleep. A feeling of stability and serenity because my energy is balanced.
And total peace of mind because I'm being protected from the negative energy of EMF radiation.
I even sleep in my bracelet to bring me peace and harmony around the clock, plus it's cute, versatile, and easy to wear.
The bracelet's made from a braided leather with an easy magnetic class. It goes with all my outfits for sure.
It's also available in black with a silver class and an all black version.
Plus, we offer a beautiful health and harmony necklace, with a hand crafted wooden pendant. Also infused with the same great bio-resonance energies.
This necklace comes in contact with the energy points in my neck, so like the bracelet, my body accepts the frequencies throughout my whole energy system.
You can benefit when you wear just the bracelet or the necklace or hit both meridian points at once when you wear them together.
This jewelry would be attractive and fun to wear even without our proprietary bio-resonance energy within.
But I love that these are powerful and beautiful tools for my health and well-being.
It's bringing energy close to the heart and the hand, and I love that.